le véhicule s des lots est un des
quartiers les plus emblématiques de
caracas dont la réputation n'a pas
toujours été très bonne hier deux
journalistes ont été arrêtés depuis on
se méfie de tout le monde
avec ou sans visa il faut aller au bon
endroit et surtout avec des gens de
confiance
ici on a l'impression qu'au coach avait
ce n'est pas mort les pénuries se font
sentir forcément cet homme vend les
fruits et les légumes en avance de la
livraison demain la monnaie dans ce pays
d'hyperinflation d'un million pour cent
par an c'est le panale la monnaie du
quartier 50 panale permettent d'acheter
un pain c'est moins cher que des bolivar
est plus stable
il est pas là et abidal comme les
services publics et la sécurité font
défaut la communauté de sierra maestra a
pris les choses en main des gens de
l'eau téléphone internet la criminalité
a baissé
le conseil communal s'est construit un
bureau avec en haut un entrepôt de
vêtements vendus pas cher on reste
fidèle au gouvernement maduro mais il ya
des critiques
il ya des défauts pas de contrôle sur ce
que le gouvernement fournit des
entreprises fantômes qui s'approprient
les dollars mais de là à changer le
gouvernement
non c'est la faute de la droite la
tension est très nette
les médias nationaux critique la
confiscation par les états unis des
avoirs pétroliers du venezuela et tout
l'appareil sur le pied de guerre
on parle d'une invasion américaine
prochaine par la colombie on ne parle
que de ça pas de sympathie ici pour
l'opposition
quand on lui demande ce que le
gouvernement devrait faire avec juan
garrido qui s'est proclamé président par
intérim en attendant des élections
l'entrée sont en prison car et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que le gouvernement de
nicolas sma de l'eau a fait de tous ses
prédécesseurs jugés condamnés en prison
ou en exil
c'est pour ça que juan garrido a dénoncé
la visite inopinée de policiers à son
domicile où se trouvaient seuls sa femme
et son enfant
la famille c'est sacré dit il ils ne
parviendront pas à briser la famille
vénézuélienne forte tension donc dans un
pays hautement polarisé à la veille de
manifestations monstres
d'un côté les rouges de l'autre les
blocs d'une opposition renforcée par un
appui international sans précédent
c'est comme d'habitude à celui qui aura
la plus grosse manifestation jean michel
leprince est du canada
caracas